yeah you work up into this blitz video
oh my god please do not start totally
back but I'm ready to do some Blitz
videos again so let's hope it works out
okay I'm definitely rusty having not
played for a week but let's see what
happens playing I am fungal fanned him
yeah the exchange I've always switched
between various sidelines him okay I try
this one I never liked the old main line
with the f6 always felt that this is
this is certainly okay yeah but I always
felt if somewhat somewhat yeah
uncomfortable so I'm losing lots of time
with my setup but from a structural
point of view black is very okay the
question is can you exploit this lack of
development and went to d8 to keep 95
out of the picture maybe I could have
gone to age 5 even though rookie five
then is an option d 4 is the most
natural move now he might try to find
something better of course d 3 okay so i
have to do have to prevent 95 so i guess
i have to so Bishop e7 to cover g5 yeah
I guess I expected this idea that I
don't quite I'm not quite sure what the
point
if I do this night eg5 I just dropped
back to d7 and h6 is just coming I Scott
95 but then I can't castle okay he's
going with this that makes sense
definitely down 5790 sf6 so moving the
bishop is not really fantastic take only
form isn't fantastic either that's not
good that's a good move okay if I take a
fall is going to take is six very
uncomfortable
okay so not good
I wonder how bad that actually is if I
go be 55 it is probably pretty bad
now Canada just said that's pretty awful
but the other things also we also very
bad okay night xe6 is kind of kind of
obvious why did you take time on that
move anyway so I don't have any trickery
en night takes f to decide what is it I
take a as 90-87 which is pretty pretty
awful p.m. and that definitely is
uncomfortable so I can try to keep it
for a moment the pawn but it will be
difficult to do in the long run yeah I'm
just losing this point
so Knight f6 was bad i have to moonlight
at age six foot I don't think I can be
much worth in that situation but night
f2g 5 was very very uncomfortable I mean
uncomfortable is putting it mildly he
might have c4 here by the way I just
spotted this that could be quite a
disaster
of course she's taking only six is not
bad but it might not be the easiest
technical thing quintic v6 is not the
best movie i think i'm not quite sure
what i'm playing after c4 to be a
perfectly honest if i take on these
three the screen takes c6 far to believe
that this should be any good
sorry for the sound in the background
case you hear that doing my laundry so
what is he thinking about probably see
form rook takes ecigs King f7 is also
fine I mean he is better also here it
was a little bit surprising that he
didn't go see for what take just a
kissing
after that you might just take a fairly
fairly bad ending
and then we look at for coming as a
position is just extremely bad even
though it probably didn't punish me the
hardest possible way of it it's still
pretty bad if i get is like Ruby 17g age
will get 6 i'm defending this check but
maybe I'm not time learning will get 6 I
cannot play yeah maybe King edge 80 just
takes h6o that's possible
[Music]
anyway let's true maybe not so bad look
at one I can go Queen d2 covering h6
extremely strange place okay anyway
check check create check not much made
next move black rosanna extremely
strange game in many ways tf1 lose
clinking of one anyway so let's have a
look there I'm going to a little bit
rusty yeah how does that work so let's
flick in the computer him so we have to
slime and here I wasn't sure where to go
i mean i was experimenting with this
specially 65 here Jim yeah between age
five this looked a little bit little bit
weird okay so i was back he played these
three not the more obvious looking move
deform i really wonder why i took far
more natural but ok d3 i went here it's
like 94 and here i have to play h6 it
seems this wasn't good due to his
response so i have to spend this move
which is not ideal I mean yeah again
moving this flank on but the fact is if
I do Knight f6 and castle and he's not
going to punish me in a direct wave and
just be very ok this is I've got the two
bishops and
perfectly fine structure so the the
engine here it gives the line with c3
that's interesting and 94 they have
tried to demolish the pawn structure
that makes lots of sense of course I
wonder I me like a second to this trying
to prevent that but it's very slow I a
necessity for him probably this clean DD
5 and 2886 is better than and now in
this though and i took a bit long for
for this and now seaforth strongest just
fairly obvious i think he spent ages for
Bishop t2 which really lets me a little
bit of the hook yes before I don't have
a good move i cannot go here yeah
because now i cannot go on The X Files
you to look takes f6 like this the Queen
and no yeah i saw this as i have to play
and black hope hope I'm surviving I
didn't see the smooth though stronger
for rookie one and rookie form so I'm
losing the Queen air let's just very bad
after 61 so King f7 I should've castles
long became yeah I didn't I didn't want
to give this up so readily z u6 pawn
yeah here Queen at five is something
that I rigidly considered but what can
just trade up everything and we'll put
the Windy lending I think the spawn
structure is too bad
Jeff so I took them and now i am it's
pretty awful still ok so we are clean
before and now i'm off the Hopi a note
that that wasn't so successful King f110
that's a really strange move somehow I
feel like that let's move I would never
play probably wrong it did feel this
feel strange I cannot tell you what I
would play to be perfectly honest the
end it wants to play with a g4 already
set this is equal yeah I've got some
call to play I mean here these are all
which this is a bit vulnerable and I
already spotted that this is a long
check quite clearly and here y has to be
has to be happy that he can make a draw
[Music]
it's sad this also looked quite good to
be honest every year but still this is
probably wrong then I was tempted to
take so that d3 might be possible to
take but the computer just covers
everything and kind of ask right okay
well what you got and probably he
doesn't have all that much ok nice so
that's the better structure and I'm not
having something akia yeah I know maybe
I'm okay I mean a double look ending for
example I won't lose ok and this is now
is better for white again okay
yes yeah that was made but I'm not going
to hold this for 13 second and in
seconds anyway yeah that opening result
was um what was pretty bad but somehow I
got back into it but ultimately he he
played plated world ok guys thanks for
watching